today we're talking about the myth that
after effects requires a super computer
let's discuss
[Music]
hey everyone my name is Cameron with
motion science and before we dive head
first into today's video I've got a
little something that will revolutionize
the way you approach motion design if
you're tired of your motion design your
Motion Graphics looking too digital
lacking that organic and tactile feel
that truly captivates audiences then
I've got a solution for you I've put
together a downloadable PDF that's about
to become your secret weapon it's called
the complete guide to mastering organic
motion design and this is not your
typical run-of-the-mill guide this guide
is packed with Insider tips and tricks
that will elevate your motion designs to
a whole new level inside you'll discover
techniques that will breathe life into
your work making it feel more human and
less like a digital render straight out
of a computer you can get your hands on
this guide of knowledge absolutely free
all you have to do is head over to
motionscience.tv guide to claim your
copy consider it my gift to you we're
all about growth creativity and pushing
boundaries together and this guide is
the next step in that Epic Journey so
don't wait head over to motionscience.tv
guide and grab your free guide right now
to create awe-inspiring organic motion
designs that leave a lasting impression
now back to today's video where we're
diving deep into the world of Adobe
After Effects to address a common
misconception that has been floating
around for years and that misconception
is that after effects requires a super
computer to run smoothly so let's get
right into it first things first let's
clarify whether you should go for a Mac
or a PC for After Effects the great news
is that both Mac and Windows computers
are excellent choices and the mac and
windows versions of After Effects
operate identical so you're not missing
out on any features regardless of your
choice Mac or PC ultimately the decision
between Mac and PC boils down to
personal preference and it support so
consider your comfort level with the
operating systems and choose what suits
you best me personally I'm a Mac guy now
let's talk about the key components that
you need for a smooth After Effects
experience you need to pay close
attention to these factors when building
out your system first and foremost a
fast processor is crucial especially if
you're actively working in After Effects
by actively working I mean tasks like if
you're animating you're doing visual
effects you're using heavy third-party
effects you need a CPU with a high
single core clock speed that's ideal for
me personally at the time of this
recording and it's August 2023 I'm still
working primarily on a 4.2 gigahertz
quad-core Intel i7 on my 2017 iMac and
an M1 chip on my MacBook Pro as my
backup machine now these CPUs get the
job done still again it's 2023 and I'm
using a 2017 iMac as my primary system
if I was looking to purchase and put
together a new system today I would look
at the Intel I9 series The AMD r Horizon
9 series and the newest M2 Pro or Max
chips these are all excellent choices
for fast CPUs on the other hand if you
mainly use your computer for Passive
tasks like rendering projects let's say
you're setting up a rendering form you
need to opt for a CPU with more cores
the more cores and the higher clocks the
better as After Effects benefits from
additional cores and multi-frame
rendering up to a point next up we have
RAM memory and as you work on a
composition After Effects temporarily
stores some rendered frames and Source
images in Ram so that previewing and
editing can occur more quickly you can
never have too much RAM for After
Effects I'll repeat that again you can
never have too much RAM now you can get
by with 16 gigs of RAM but I would
definitely recommend more at least 32
gigs of RAM is recommended for serious
after effects use and if you're dealing
with a complex project or you're working
in 16 or 32-bit color depths which I
typically always recommend at least 16
bit consider 64 gigs or even more RAM if
you can do it again this is August 2023
and my current setup is a 2017 iMac but
I do have 64 gigs of ram in that system
my next system will include even more
also an important reminder is having at
least two Ram modules in a dual Channel
configuration will give you double the
potential bandwidth enhancing memory
access and speeding things up like
animation previews now let's talk about
storage for smooth previews and
rendering fast storage is essential SSD
and nvme offer exceptional performance
and outperform traditional drives in an
ideal world you would use three
different storage drives you're using
one drive for project storage one for
application storage and one for cache
file storage if you're working on
complex projects I would highly consider
investing in these three drives to keep
everything running smoothly now let's
talk about GPU well after effects relies
more on CPU performance a strong GPU can
provide noticeable speed ups when using
certain effects or plugins additionally
if you work with 3D projects and utilize
the after effects cineware engine
multiple gpus can greatly enhance
performance now for most After Effects
workloads a good CPU is hands down the
most important thing but having a
capable GPU will be beneficial for
specific tasks now I get asked all the
time What GPU I personally use my answer
is whatever Apple includes within their
computers with today's M chips the gpus
are getting really good I've never
personally found that I need anything
other than what's built into the Mac
computer for the work that I do but do
keep in mind that I mostly do two and
two and a half D work in After Effects
with a little bit of 3D here and there
I'm not working with complex 3D projects
that would benefit from high level gpus
so if you're working primarily in After
Effects you don't need some high level
GPU or extra General GPU system so there
you have it the myth is busted after
effects does not require a super
computer to run smoothly with the right
components such as a fast processor
sufficient Ram a capable GPU and fast
storage you can really enjoy a fantastic
After Effects experience whether you're
a Mac Enthusiast or a PC Aficionado
remember that the choice between the two
is all about personal preference so go
ahead and build the perfect workstation
for your After Effects Endeavors and
before we end today's video I do want to
remind you go to motionscience.tv guide
to pick up your free copy of the
complete guide to organic motion design
as always thank you so much for being
here with me today I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]
thank you